Thanks welcome back thanks for the kind
introduction thanks for the invitation
and thanks to the organizers for all the
effort and sweat of setting up this
splendid workshop on challenges in
quantum computation and well this is
what this talk will be about or actually
rather more on the challenges a
non-literal quantum computing in that we
have a look at a specific ramification
thereof namely that of analog quantum
simulators in a way the the dirty
brothers of quantum computers so but I
will try to advocate that they are still
devices worth thinking about that
they're quite exciting devices and
sometimes underappreciated so what
specifically asked by the organizers to
say something about what what we have
what we would like to have and the
potential for seeing quantum advantages
this is a challenging prescription and
well I will obviously not be
comprehensive so we'll ask lots of
questions and throughout this talk like
what is a another quantum simulator in
the first place then what are relevant
problems and when and it what sense can
we hope to quantum simulators to provide
some kind of computational speed-up over
classical computers this is far from
being being obvious I mean for say full
shor class fault-tolerant quantum
computers the speed-up issue may be out
of question in that they could
presumably solve some NP problems in
polynomial time and we've seen and we
are kind of witnessing very exciting and
activities towards actually building
such devices we will hear talk tomorrow
by John Martinez on realizing like
superconducting qubit devices up to like
50 superconducting qubits that's very
exciting indeed but this is large by
some measures but it's not the full
short class quantum large-scale quantum
device that we that we hopeful
on large-scale devices however the one
thing we do have
as of today with present technology is
quantum simulators so a large scale
devices that offer a high level of
precision and control but not quite
enough to be Universal computers so I
mean that's the dirty brothers of
quantum computers but they're one thing
they are large so the the asymptotic
limit is in a way already built but then
loads of new questions pop up say I mean
analog quantum simulators are made to
simulate interesting physics problems
but in a way that are stimulating
themselves so they are surely not be
could be complete so what is the precise
computational power of such analog and
simulators then error correction let
alone for tolerance we'll be out of the
question so is this is this a back or a
feature meaning does that necessarily
mean that we are just swarmed with noise
they're all just solving problems in P
or is there some sort of inherent
robustness so that at least an
intermediate times and space regimes
there's something potentially
interesting coming out of that I'm not
necessarily having answers but there's
an important question that we should
pose so clearly mark in quantum
simulator things but there's most point
to the idea of a quantum simulation if
one simulates problems for which there's
good evidence that we could not have
done otherwise so in in one way or the
other we would like to solve problems
that are inaccessible to classical
computers so they should solve hard
problems in a certain sense so let's
assume one day I got into a lab and
there was a talk somebody else goes into
a lab and performs a quantum simulation
that's presumably interesting meaning
for which there are some evidence that
is solving a hard problem of a kind and
then this person performs a delicate
measurement at the end and the outcome
is
five is this correct well how would we
know it's not an NP problem so and so
how can we how can we it be claimed that
a system has been successfully similar
eight and how can you even think of
having testable advantages of a certain
kind and while I do not
Nestle of course answers to that is this
will be one of the the guiding questions
throughout this talk and here's a
question that we have to have answered
in a way so analog simulator so any
simulator is clearly an analog simulator
in that it's well it's in the nature of
simulation that it's analog to the real
thing but analog simulators are analog
analog like not being discrete right so
like analog classical computers now
quantum analog simulators are basically
made to probe interesting physics
questions not so much quantum chemistry
problems as was hinted at in the
previous discussions are made to look at
interesting physics problems of a kind
so here's a kind of a minimum
requirement said what it could could
mean so there's clearly kind of a system
size coming into play like n that
governs like how large a system we can
address this will usually be like local
Hamiltonian problems that have some sort
of knobs that you can tune in the lab
that require some level or give rise to
some level of control there's surely
some noise levels that can be assessed
and and in characterized but there's
surely no noise ever and what it's
important here that there's only certain
class of preparations that are
conceivable and more importantly even
certain kinds of measurements that can
be done at the end of the day so this is
usually a very strong limitation in an
analog simulator what kind of read out
one can meaningfully conceive in a
practical setting so the most advanced
such architecture is that of code atoms
in optical lattices or stained
artificial lattice is made from
counter-propagating laser lights like an
egg carton where the the
carton is the the light and the eggs are
the atoms just sitting there one by one
so I'd like to cite Ian's worms in this
context he was once after talk asked
whether this protocol he was just
showing could also be done in the
asymptotic limit whereas he said we're
experimentalists we are not asymptotic
people yet this is kind of different in
that this is asymptotic in the sense
that one has access to very large like
ten to the power of five even ten to the
power of six sites and atoms in today
and experiments in 1d 2d and 3d node
bosons and fermions into such a lattice
there's some tunability in the sense
what can't one can look at super
lattices Feshbach resonance so there's
some knobs one can turn to probe that
systems under certain different settings
there's time-of-flight measurements
that's basically like a for a
measurement on the full thing and in
situ measurement which means that one
can measure on sites a sample atom
numbers and at the end on site so here's
the input here well I mean there's
progress on realizing programmable such
potentials this will come up soon like
in a monoblock slab which is an
interesting and further perspective then
next on the list
is that of trapped ions these are way
smaller like twenty is up to 53 in
experiment that will be reported on
tomorrow these are devices where one has
pretty much universal control although
one some gates some global gates like
Marie Messerly gates are easier than
others but one can do in principle a
universal set and also one can gain
tomographic knowledge at the end of the
day say with compressed sensing
techniques one can learn about the state
at pretty large system sizes which we
just did with a for the blood group and
so one can basically read out the system
at at the end so these are the the most
well-known architectures there's also
optical micro traps that come in large
tunable arrays but they like long ranged
easing in a way there is Polara tonic
and photo
architectures which are very exciting
they're very tunable but they also
intrinsically open and very noisy so
they're kind of low variant simulators
if you want and we will here by Misha
who's sitting here tomorrow about
chapter called atoms in rhetoric States
which are in a certain sense
programmable which is again an exciting
and perspective so one of the problems
they can probe after all so very natural
problems are like time-dependent
problems that quenches where you go to
the lab have a state initially prepared
and then you look at the time evolution
under longer and longer times generated
by some local and atonium probing
questions of equilibration
thermalization and how temperatures they
comes about in in the first place now a
picture that like I'd like to show in
this context because it shows the kind
of paradigmatic setting that we have in
mind here is this one here that shows
the result of a kind of dynamical
simulation of such a kind which shows
the setting where you have prepared in a
car basically of one-dimensional setting
the initial situation of zero one zero
one zero one zero one prepared in the
lab and then one looks at the time
evolution under strongly correlated
Hamiltonian for longer and longer times
and looks at the number of odd particles
as a function of time and there's
initially no odd particles at all and
then you have some non equilibrium exit
for long times maybe unsurprising just
half a particle per cell no there's a
lot to say about this experiment and ask
me maybe later because this is quite
interesting but for the purposes of our
line of thought it's interesting to see
that this picture not only shows the
result of a dynamical quantum simulation
but also the results of a classical
riess emulation sort of fit but a
classical simulation at the blue curve
and that fits that is a very nice
agreement the point is that this is not
just some simulation but it was run at
the time on the fastest algorithm that's
available for that type of problem
cymatics product state it was run by the
on the fastest computer the German
taxpayer can afford in the Hughley
supercomputing Center and it took like
five weeks of run time to generate a
plot of this kind so this is kind of the
the upper bound of a of a publishable
result of that kind and that's very
nicely working for short times even with
error bars if you want but there's a
certain point where even with five
thousand by five thousand matrices you
can no longer go on because for the
entanglement growth one cannot
faithfully approximate the state anymore
at a given instance in time there is an
interesting situation that well the
experiment of course runs on and one can
ask better physics question on the
dynamical simulation can use this
classical real simulation as a way to
build trust in the functioning of the
device I don't want to say verification
but build trust and eventually up to a
point but the experiment runs on and in
a mild way outperforms the classical
supercomputer of course one should be
careful I mean it's not so difficult to
think of like mean field fits or sort of
a kind but there can be two fallacies
here in the sense that one doesn't want
to reproduce just one plot at a time but
a full functional dependence which is
hard and also it's also not about just
richer addicting what is there but also
rather having predictive power of what
comes out at the end of the day this is
a much more challenging prescription so
these are the namaka problems then one
can think of slow parameter variations
of a type that are reminiscent of
adiabatic quantum computing looking at
cables Uruk type settings which one can
do in 1d Beavan can classically reason
were at everything with all details but
the quantum simulation can be in 2d one
can look at ground state problems and
the holy grail here is that of the
hubbard model that's thought to play a
role in high-temperature
superconductivity where the issue here
is really to cool it down to the cold
enough temperatures to see like
long-range order but there's been
significant progress and recently and on
that type of endeavor or many-body
localization where this order and
interactions come together where it's
debated whether this MV alpha is even
exists in two
again one can check everything nicely in
1d but the experiment can be done in an
in 2d in just the same way as as before
so the upshot I'm trying to make here is
that these are kind of baby steps
obviously but baby steps in an
interesting direction in the sense that
there's certain regimes that are
classically verifiable and like short
times can be efficiently simulated long
times not in this kind of Kubrick type
setting in 1d one can completely reese
emulate things on a classical computer
in with Polara bars but not
two-dimensional systems on a classical
computer but quantumly one can perfectly
do so this is sometimes underappreciated
but one should be aware of the point
that exists in quantum simulators
already outperform
state-of-the-art classical algorithms
run on classical supercomputers in in
this in this in this sense this is a
very interesting kind of baby step in
the right direction of course one can
argue fine it's it this is very
interesting but there could always be a
better better algorithm and I mean who
are we to say that this kind of you
outperform state-of-the-art algorithms
but there could be a kind of a better
way of looking at it and a clever
simulation method so how can we be sure
against this kind of devil's advocate
argument of a type so to be safe against
a lack of imagination one would like to
see some sort of hardness of a task in a
complexity theoretic sense so presumably
one would like to have some look at some
sort of intermediate problem like which
is say outside PPP but not bqp complete
so that like some problem that can be
realized in the lab under natural
settings which however shows some sort
of speed-up of a kind and this brings us
to the question of achieving super
polynomial and speed ups of the car so
this is kind of like the concept
previously known as quantum supremacy or
so although I realized that this word is
coming a bit in this favor
so here the at stake is to have some
problem that's reason realizable in the
lab no matter how practical or or
applied that is to just show some
problem for which there's good evidence
of a speed-up over classical computers
in a complexity theoretical no no no
matter no matter what and one of the
seminal papers in the direction was on
so-called boson sampling which is a cute
simple relatively simple prescription we
have on things of having bosons and
sends them to a random linear optical
multi-port and samples from the photon
number distribution at the end of the
day and that's interesting because the
distribution this random distribution
obtained in this fashion is so intricate
although random so that one cannot
resample this on a classical computer to
a great accuracy or precisely when a
sampling from a distribution close to an
additive total error in the total
variation distance is computationally
harder would lead to a collapse of the
paranormal hierarchy if this unitary in
this algorithm is chosen how random and
the number of photons is scaling
appropriately with the number of modes
to that a second yeah very much so
yeah indeed under reasonable complexity
theoretical assumptions which I will
come to in a minute indeed absolutely
right and this I mean this may not be
very scalable experimentally but this
was a key seminal paper in the sense
that it not only set the setting and
also the complexity theory the
assumption that I will come to in a
minute but also introduced some nice
proof techniques that we will hint at at
least in in a second now there's also am
i QP and random circuits I understand
that we will hear a bit more about this
tomorrow morning there is easing type
interactions that are maybe closest to
spirit in what I'm going to
say in a minute although they rely on
settings that have a unit cell of 56
cubits and why this is paradigmatic a
very interesting one can argue that if
you have a unit cell of fifty six cubits
that's not really meant to be a
practical scheme of overtime so so these
questions one thing is how come on
how can we think of verification in and
testing in such a setting like blackbox
verification seems out of a question
that maybe not so surprising that with
but a normally many samples one cannot
distinguish such a device from one that
could be classically efficiently and
emulated so one has to think a little
bit harder in verifying such devices
what is more even though this is way
simpler than thinking of universal
quantum computers these are still very
very intricate and challenging
prescriptions so so is it possible to
scale such prescriptions up to provably
heart regimes in architectures that are
close to quantum simulations of a kind
that we have just just advocated well
this is the the regime I come to that in
the setting of similar assumption of the
type we're about to mention in a second
to have kind of a setting way cannot
resample the problem up to constant
error in the total version distance I
come to this innocent so I mean this is
what you what you want you are going to
have a kind of a boson fabric
typesetting which kind of combines the
benefit of both words where you want to
see a kind of a a quench type
architecture so it's some sort of
scalable architecture but that should
not involve like like complicated or
Hamiltonians or 56 cubed unit cells or
so but you won't have a Hamiltonian
setting like with nearest neighbor or at
best nearest neighbor situation that you
look at but where you get heartless
proofs with the constant l1 norm error
under certain assumptions I will come to
in in a second this is what one would
would like to see and I'm using the next
five minutes to say that such
architectures indeed exist one can think
of such setting
some involve randomness other stone but
for reasons of time' but only briefly
sketch the one thing on the left that
does involve some kind of randomness is
a very simple prescription what wonders
is that one has a square lattice and
initially prepares that these qubits on
this lattice initially in a product
state there's some randomness involved
but there's no correlation whatsoever so
one can think of this as being the
ground set of a disordered Hamiltonian
if you want to but it's just a product
state initially of that setting then one
looks at the evolution in time under
local Emmy Tony but not some complicated
Hamiltonian not a fifty-six unit cell or
whatnot but just the simplest
Hamiltonian I can imagine namely a
nearest neighbor easing Hamiltonian
would not offer for long times but for
one unit of time it's a unit depth
circuit if you want applied for one unit
of time now this cannot only be done
with present technology but has already
been done this was one of the earliest
experiments for called atoms like these
controlled collisions that were done
that even predated the cluster state
computers the one way computing that the
one that computing comes out of the
discussion of the cold collisions in
these optical lattice experiments turn
on hyperfine levels basically
implementing and easing Hamiltonian so
you do like one unit time of Hamiltonian
and then you measure all qubits in the X
basis you just sample from them now
experimentally this I mean single side
addressing is possible but this has to
be done product quite accurately so this
is presumably the the simplest the most
difficult prescription but the over
scheme is as simple as it gets you
prepare a product state one unit of time
of a nearest neighbor Newtonian or unit
depth circuit but commuting gates and
just sample at the end of the day
there's no other randomness no gates
involved here whatsoever and the claim
is that under three Ida plausible
complex systematic assumptions I say
that in the second one cannot
efficiently sample from the outcome
distribution and a scheme up to constant
error in the l1 distance that's similar
to the setting impose on sampling but it
kind of in a scalable Hamiltonian
fashion of this kind so I have no time
to go into detail of the argument about
22 minutes but I will say a few words on
how this goes like to give a bit of a
bit of hint at the argument so there's
no gates no random unitary is no
measurement no adaption in the in the
scheme but one relates that setting to a
measurement based computing setting a
post selected and bqc setting that
measurement are being done in the XY
plane which is it turns related to a
random circuit with T Guedes that gates
controls it and harder mods that are
being done which is a universal quantum
circuit for which is a post pika p.m.
and complete setting which already means
that it's sharply hard to approximate
the output distribution of the kind but
you don't want to approximate the output
distribution but you want to show
hardness of actually sampling from that
distribution that alone would already
say that you cannot sample from that
distribution up to small multi bit
market multiplicative errors but that's
not very physical so under further
assumptions namely of an anti
concentration of the distribution and on
an average case complexity conjecture
one can use the machinery of stock
Maya's algorithm to make beef up the
arrow you can tolerate from
multiplicative errors to reasonably
physical additive errors at the end of
the at the end of the day so for the
published work this was an assumption
but in the meantime we worked harder on
actually proving the anti concentration
bounds for certain settings of the type
and also won some leverage can be done
on average case complexity nice nice
work by omage maybe also set down
recently together with adam to see how
this can be combined so this together
shows that you can do that up to
additive errors in the total variation
this is one cannot resemble from that
distribution so that's a setting where
you can do like a quench setting in the
lab under just a Hamiltonian setting yet
you cannot sample from the distribution
up to an additive error in the total
variation distance on a classical
computer off you guys so this is a
quantum well simulation if you want
that's intractable on quantum computers
in a
kind of nicely scalable fashion there's
another beautiful feature I will say at
the very end which is the following
maybe it's in a very nice and strong way
verifiable which is a kind of a cute
aspect of this in the following sense so
one can just go into the lab and make
order n measurements of a kind and this
will not just build trust in the
functioning of the device or build some
evidence that one has done the right
thing but the quantity measured directly
bounds the the TransAm and they actually
the l1 distance of the final
distribution that enters the complexity
theoretic argument so this kind of
interesting in the sense that one would
go into the lab and perform a
measurement and if the noise levels are
too high then one would say the noise
levels are too high and then one has to
the red light goes on one says or we
have to abort because it's not not the
right thing because that that's actually
this part is not very deep it's like the
point is that this is a ground state of
affixes frustration-free Hamiltonian so
basically the the it's not so much the
the verification that's so interesting
but the fact that you can do a scheme of
that type with a unit depth circuit so
what you ultimately do is you think of
this as a as a unique ground set of a
frustration-free Hamiltonian so you can
do this locally but that's measuring
local Hamiltonian terms one by one and
if this fidelity is large enough you can
unambiguously state that the overall
state must be closed and traced on to
the right state and that you can infer
to the to the bound to the total
variation this is that's only possible
because the depth that the circuit is a
short circuit a unit depth circuit and
then the verification is basically not
so is it not I'm not relying on the
assumption the point is in its it is a
ground state a fixture semi talking but
I repeat measurements and then if I get
sufficiently many times as efficiently
close value to the right thing you can
you can upgrade you can argue from this
that you're closing total version
the faucet I can give you you have lots
of discussions time afterwards yeah okay
good
I mean I could come to that it does make
some assumptions but not too strong ones
in the center if I can the whole thing
is true up to additive error so to the
extent that you do some sort of that the
you can relate that error to them the
measurement with the state error then
you can still accept some errors of a
kind and I can also bound the errors you
can tolerate yeah but it's kind of cute
to see that that's a setting that's
because you do a unit depth circuit that
you do measurements sequentially of
local measurements and from that alone
also accepting additive errors on the
measurement device if you want you can
infer that well if the noise levels are
too high you have to abort but if this
measurement including measurement errors
would be close enough to the right state
you can get green light and say but then
that means that the distribution you get
is necessarily closed in to order
version this is to the real thing which
is a secured property to have in this
this kind of setting so we do
measurements and then it's a it's a
setting that is kind of in a very
stringent way verifiable I should say
that this idea also would work for the
superconducting devices we're just
talking to - Sergio that this is a nice
feature to have so this is a challenging
prescription that the measurements
should be not so uh naked indeed but
truly it's way simpler than for torrents
and it's it's a very stringent way of a
verification of a kind
okay good which brings me to the so
here's that is the point so this is a a
prejudice often aired in the in the
physics communities that oh yeah in
order to be able to verify a quantum
simulation one needs to be able to
efficiently verify it and close it as it
sounds I mean this is fortunately not
true I mean that's delicate settings
where one can verify quantum devices in
a certain way even if the classical
simulation is beyond reach so also in
the verification setting just outlined
you would get numbers and if you get a
green light you would say oh then the
sampling distribution is right they say
about what is it what you don't know you
have to go into the lab so that's kind
of cue to see that the verification of a
device is less than predicting the
outcome and in particular and physics
communities that's not uh not
appreciated this is something less and
that you can verify the functioning of a
device even if you cannot predict what
comes out at the end of the day which is
important to have in mind when thinking
of analog and quantum simulation which
brings me to the end of my talk because
I don't want overrun but we have still
time to discuss in the in the in the
it's time so we have looked at analog
quantum simulations the the thirty
brothers of quantum computers and we
would like to know more about them and
that's what I'm trying to advocate there
we look at certain platforms of them and
looked at interesting questions they can
potentially pro of time evolution slope
ranges and ground set problems and it's
important to stress that already present
a quantum simulators tables called atoms
do outperform the best known algorithms
for the same type of problem run on
classical supercomputers this may not be
the end of the story but it's already
interesting that for physicists that's
already often enough what they want to
hear interestingly yeah
anyway I'm to be safe one would like to
have some sort of feasible quantum
simulator for which one can make a claim
of a super polynomial speed-up in terms
in a language of computational
complexity and we also have had a look
at in this talk we looked at a scheme
that is interesting and it says it's not
fault all right but it can be kind of
certified in a very stringent and nice
sense it can be seen as kind of a a bell
test for quantum computing so even if
the simulators exhibit a quantum
computation speed-up there's still a
strong say
in which one can verify that the
functioning of the device which is a
kind of acute and property to have this
is nice however but should be aware of
the fact that there's still a bit of a
disk on doin's between the the physical
schemes that are physically meaningful
and interesting and the settings where
one can prove something in terms of a
language of computational complexities
of a carbon bring these words a bit
closer together more structure problems
look at MBL problems disorder problems
that for which come one can prove
something which were closer to the ones
that are in that are interesting from a
physics perspective then the question of
robustness of quantum simulators i
didn't say so much about that but that's
of course an interesting issue important
issue they read out what is often very
limited in the way one can read out
quantum simulators so that's something
one has to work more on to to to make
progress here and in the end maybe it's
interesting to see that there's kind of
a trade-off between space and time in
any any quantum algorithm in this
setting it's kind of cute to see that
this kind of space and time trade-off
can be brought to the extreme in the
sense that the scheme is one that only
has space and no time because it's a
unit depth circuit being applied is but
a large spatial system will unit depth
circuit for which one can still show us
kind of some sort of speed-up of a kind
in in that setting which brings me to
the end of the talk thanks for your
attention I'm looking forward with the
questions you might potentially have
yeah oh yeah sure that's very easy
because I mean I can very good
I mean the point is very very simple in
the tender picture you would have a I
mean look so it's just a product set and
these guys are random from like iid
random from a chosen with a randomly
chosen but chosen stare fixed you fix
the randomness and that's what you have
and then you do a kind of a circuit of
the kind you can see that they're kind
of bricklayer thing these are all
commuting so the order doesn't matter
right because that's a thing on the Tony
on but it you can't rather eyes they're
just sick think that of a unity a
circuit of that kind right you do this
in 2d but that's the same thing okay and
then you get a state and then look I
mean the fact that that this kind of
certification is possible that it's a
fixed ground state isn't this picture
obvious because look what you get in
this form put like in 1d if you contract
that network would be like if you write
it like that it will be in matrix
product state of point I mentioned two
or in 2d it would be a peps of point I
mentioned to us contract it in okay no
okay look okay okay look this guy is
okay this is the the bond dimension to
matrix product state okay every matrix
products it is a ground state of a
Hamiltonian if it's an injective MPs I
say about this in a
then it would be you get the unique
grande set of Amazonian this would be a
three local Hamiltonian so what did
basically if this look at make it
simpler I do it just set zeros zebras
one okay because that's the same idea
same thing and then you have a kind of
this guy would be an easing on the
Tholian like a set I is that I plus one
the sky and then what this is baby like
an X Y Z I plus 1 z IX I am at Orion
basically it's a three local Amazonia
and of that it's the the unique onset
interesting bit is not so much that you
can do I mean once you acknowledge that
this is a matrix products a ripe EPS in
one dimension to then that you can do a
verification by measuring the fixed
semitone that would also work for 2d if
I had the same in 2d I would get basic
vigor like an x z x ZX x Hamiltonian
okay this is not so deep se but what is
kind of cute is that you have a setting
where you just apply a unit depth
circuit that gives us no no but yes yes
very much so thank you very much
it's exactly it I just conjugated you
can say that but the point is is a local
thing right you can just measure it I
mean I mean that is extremely simple you
just you conjugate the Hamiltonian
another thing but the point is if you
get the measurement the right
expectation values you can still write
it in a week membership form to really
say that your absent close to the to the
right P Dalit that's why it's possible
yeah are you assuming
that there is a single global state
which is the same state regardless of
which observable you're measuring say
say say it again about verification of
bosons and play like that would not know
what's the assumption no way there is a
single state so in other words you know
if we just think of the quantum computer
as a black box right oh but this is this
is the point and this is I mean no no
it's it's no no no it's okay it's not an
answer in response to each measurement
you know basis that you asked about you
know but rather to commit to a single
global state which then you know the
expectation values of all of these
measurements will be calculated with
respect to that state that's important
to stress maybe maybe I wasn't clear
enough about in the sense because the
point is that one is not assuming that
there is a global state right but one
takes measurements and the only state
compatible with those measurements is
that global state so there's no
additional assumption isn't no there
isn't that the point
do you take measurements and for each
measure for each setting there is only
one one stay that's compatible with that
type of measurement outcomes
we reach to the button setting it you're
pressing for it and then it outputs
statistics that are you careful that
there is no point in that case that's
the point
haha that's another interesting point
that's an interesting point and but I
personally am convinced Scott have do
you see what I'm what I mean it because
I come to that in a second okay it's a
debate I think you treat the assumption
it's so obvious that it doesn't need to
be stated okay but then I should say
more clearly what I say I'm making the
assumption that the measurement
apparatus I'm using like the local metal
in terms o kind of in a way characterize
that they don't have to be perfect but
they're close enough so that I can
accommodate this with an additive error
for the total thing this is the
assumption I make the measurements have
to be some or not too bad but that's
always the case right but I'm not making
any further assumption the sense I say
it again that for a specific setting I
make measurements and I get outcomes and
the only this is a very important to
stress and there's no further assumption
that the only state that is compatible
with the measurement outcomes is the
state that you have there's no other
state I'm not making a uniqueness
assumption so on but one can show that
the only state which is compatible with
the outcomes is the one that is correct
if you get more about this later okay
Nathan's question okay good but the
thing is that just because you know that
you're you look okay okay what will you
make measurements and what you can infer
about that measurements there's only one
state one quantum state that is
compatible with these measurements right
okay good and this you can verify and I
can do but from that model knowledge
alone he would not be able to
classically sample from the distribution
that you would have obtained by having
that state that's a maybe your point
that doesn't allow if you do it all the
classical computer of course you I mean
expectation values can be easily
computed I mean if
in your head it's just a one step cetera
automaton of course they could compute
all kinds of poll expectation values
that's very easy but the Hayate is the
distribution I cannot I cannot just from
the fact that I can write down the state
as a peps doesn't mean I can efficiently
sample from it on a classical computer
that's what we showed you cannot so
that's the interesting distinction right
that's also at the heart of the boat on
sampling that writing on the stage is a
triviality you can still not sample from
it I think maybe the buzzword a fully
sort of device-independent prescription
of what you do right here is the input
here's what the output is supposed to be
you don't need to know anything about
the internal state of the device you can
just test is the device solving this
problem what's the output sorry and then
the problem would be to verify that
right so when you say verification you
know you don't worry you know it would
mean this device independence because
again you are assuming some you know you
know that there is a single internal
state of the quantum computer which does
not depend on which measurement was
Joseph okay so it's a you know I mean I
mean that's fine okay but okay
no nobody okay but in this sense is
quite similar to pause on sampling
descent okay but we'll discuss that
later but I mean also in both ensemble
because they da I mean do measurement
adviser devices must be characterized so
it's not device independent that setting
[Music]
the same sure that's but since they the
effect of that is to produce a local
Hamiltonian yeah exactly
right exactly
no that's like I mean that's the the
setting I mean the that's all the whole
point here is that what we did basically
is to just strip then find the simplest
scheme for which an argument along
Scott's lines is possible that has
precisely the construction that you have
if you do an IQ p circuit also if a deep
circuit then I mean okay good
no no I mean indeed this can be done I
mean a similar setting can be done if
you double the setting you can you can
do a something similar for IQ PS value
also for the random circuits yeah you
can do that too locally thermolysis in
the sense at local expectation has
become as if the that's a deep question
I mean then you do you have a bit
limited time but let me talk amigo it
like it's a couple of things you say
first of all two systems thermalize
right I mean that's something I work on
a lot I mean there's a lot to say I mean
you cannot quite prove it but there's
but it's almost there in the sense that
if you have a sufficiently clustering of
correlations initial state and then you
have a sufficiently generic Hamiltonian
which is local then one should expect
that for most times the in trace norm
the reduced state would look as if the
tires is the most thermal reduce to the
subsystem that's kind of what you say
right and this is not fully proven so
there's yeah it is what it is then you
can say can you do get sampling yeah
this will presumably also be kind of as
a sampling problem no I mean did you
would do this and then it would say kind
of sample from the state right yeah
indeed and okay probably the answer is
yes but I mean these settings are
delicate in the sense that it's not so
easy to find some sort of hardest proof
so probably yes but the devil will be in
the detail of actually proving it but
it's an interesting setting but it's not
the most natural of all settings because
you're making so many assumptions along
the way that it can be hard to make
progress here but it's super interesting
as a setting I agree we should talk more
about this you know it's basically
almost pretty much you make an
assessment like on how large the system
has to be - okay good
so in this you're talking about the
overhead okay there is some something to
be said the short answer of this is make
it short so you can do this it was also
hinted at if you want to have a random
circuit of size 40 you can also do it
with two times 40 or so and then this
strong verification is still possible if
you're not happy with the quadratic
overhead you can do it and you still
that's that's kind of verification if
you're happy with the square speed up as
you say visit 40 by 40 but it
effectively be it's like a random 40
cubed setting which is nice if you want
to have like translation bar and
settings maybe it's just one Hamiltonian
as a translation one thing that's needs
that type of setting in many
architecture that's plausible then
squaring it seems an acceptable price
because you're fully translation buying
and that's it if you want to be delicate
and have like tuned circuits I don't
like overheads then you don't have that
all right so both it's possible you can
do a square thing then you get an
overhead as you rightfully say but then
you are fully charged by the in the in
the
many-body setting that's very plausible
if you don't want that then you have a
random second no no there's not it I
mean no oh but let's discuss that I mean
in any any of these schemes you have to
know something about your your
measurement devices that's not what
Scott meant but I mean this model can be
can have a discussion it was very
stimulating but it's not that I mean of
course you always have to know something
about your devices although I am not
fully happy with that
that's fair putting it because you do
again but that we discussed that more
later for the measurement outcomes there
will only be one state that's compatible
with that but let's discuss that more ok
this was interesting
thank you yeah thank you
[Applause]